outside a busy mall a gunman is caught
on camera
for a moment he appears to raise a
weapon before continuing down the stairs
this is the same man accused of shooting
shoppers in
copenhagen of killing three at random
and terrorizing countless others
beau was having dinner with his wife
when the firing started we heard the
shot for sure and uh
many seconds after we we
went down to the floor in order to
protect ourselves
so
you're hiding
you're with your family what's going
through your head then
i was extremely nervous about my wife
so my my step number one in this was i
would take care of her and protect her
for everything so that's the goal number
one i had the alleged attacker posted
pictures online posing with weapons
before sunday's attack
police say the guns used were obtained
illegally
a 22 year old danish man has been
arrested and provisionally charged with
manslaughter and attempted killing and
is being held in a psychiatric ward
it was down these steps that people fled
as they ran for their lives what
happened here has rocked this country
which has some of the strictest gun
regulations in europe
sunday's shooting is the worst gun
attack since 2015 when two people were
killed by a suspected islamic extremist
this time police have ruled out terror
the suspect was known to mental health
officials and is believed to have acted
alone gun laws are very restrictive it's
very difficult to get hands on
semi-automatic or fully automatic
weapons without the police knowing
currently the public debate is centering
around
how could public authorities and health
authorities have
seen the signals of this person having
dealing with health issues beforehand
earlier the prime minister came to pay
her respects but answers about why this
happened
for tomorrow
today denmark is mourning siobhan
robbins sky news copenhagen